اي نفق دخلوا وما المصير لكان الصوره
الرماديه انعكاس لحال الاحتلال مع غزه
ضبابيه غامضه مغلقه يشاهد ملايين الناس
يوميا فيديوهات المعارك في غزه وليس ثمه
صوره لقتال جدي امام من يراقب غير التي
تنشرها المقاومه الفلسطينيه كمين وجها
لوجه دبابات تحت رفات معارك من غرف البيوت
لا صخور في غزه لا هضاب ولا تلال فيتحول
ركام المباني التي
اريدتنزيل
مقاومه يكاد يجمع لها بانها فاقت في توازن
القوى المختل اي مقاومه في العصر
الحديث واذ لا يمكن قياس تكافؤ القوه وفق
معاير تقليديه بين جيش مجهز باقوى الاسلحه
وشبان صنعوا انفسهم وسلاحهم فان الفارق
لمراقبين يكمن في قوه الفكر والحافز
وابداع التخطيط والاحتضان الشعبي هو
الفارق بين فدائي الزقاق زقاق ارضه وجندي
المركا المحتل الغريب ذاك تحديدا ما يجعل
سؤال اليوم الاول هو نفسه سؤال ما بعد 90
هل القضاء على حماس اسما المقاومه مفهوما
امر ممكن يسمع الاسرائيليون الجواب المشكك
من واشنطن الحاميه الداعمه حين دعت
بنيامين نتنياهو بدايه الحرب الى وضع
اهداف واقعيه وها هو وزير خارجيتها بلينكن
في خامس جولاته يبلغ وفق وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي بانه لا
يمكن القضاء تماما على حماس الموقف الذي
سبقه اليه قبل ايام جون كيربي المسؤول في
الامن القومي فعلام تراهن اسرائيل ثم تراي
يقول انها واقعه في مازق اللا خيار فوقف
الحرب هزيمه واستمرارها استنزاف في العلن
ترفض اسرائيل وقف القتال في مواجهه موقف
ثابت للمقاومه يجعل اي بحث لاخراج الاسرى
وهم جنود دون وقف العدوان طرحا غير قابل
للبحث وهكذا تتحول غزه الى نفق كبير يتيه
فيه ما وصف باحد اقوى جيوش العالم ويتقاضى
قادته المسؤوليه فيما تخلو الساحه الدوليه
الا من حركه امريكيه تقفز فوق ما يحدث الى
ما يؤمل وما يحدث ان المقاومه لا تنتهي اذ
تقوم فضلا عن عقائدها الايديولوجيه على
تاسيس قانوني زم
وهو حق الانسان في مقاومه محتل ارضه يمكن
لنتنياهو ان يتحدث كثيرا وان يسرح بخياله
ليفكر كيف ينشئ اجيالا فلسطينيه تستعذب
الاحتلال وتتعلم حبه في المدارس اما على
الارض فالسلاح بالسلاح وضحايا هم خلفوا من
هجروا وسلف من يتجرعون احتلالا يفجر بحور
مقاومه يقول التاريخ ان قمات موجه اكثر من
الذاهبات الله اكبر